talk to you about Mike mihari i'm
playing over watching past couple of
months and then the beta is coming out
in a couple of months time may third may
third just around the corner yeah couple
of corners but you know just ran a
couple of corners and but we've been
playing predominantly on PC I'm most of
the gameplay we've seen has been pc but
you got to go down to blizzard and play
it on consoles yeah so I guess first of
all what did you play it on xbox one
playstation 4 i played playstation 4
Dave over in the UK dead xbox one
they've jewett yep and yeah I played
about three or four hours on ps4 mmm it
feels good feels I mean like you'd
expect I the default aiming sensitivity
felt a little slow but i think that was
mainly just because I was so used to
playing on PC where you could do a 180
degree turn and like no time flat yeah
but even so it's the game itself it's
designed to be very fast-paced so I
think a lot of people might be turning
their sensitivity up even if you're not
normally accustomed to up there's like
most the character abilities are kind of
tailored for this really like then some
cases twitchy gameplay like Widowmaker
i'm sure the sniper people are like
really good on pc with her yeah on
console it's gonna be a little more you
know adjusting if people were used to pc
but have they changed any of the heroes
abilities because like widow-makers the
one that like you play Widowmaker like
you put counter-strike sure it sits
straight aim down sights there's a
charge on the sniper rifle but it's it's
pretty much like Hanzo almost white yeah
same thing i wanta but like for instance
Winston the big ape his he's almost like
one of the easier characters because his
gun essentially like just connects to
anyone who's read so like that's one
that would be simple on consoles yeah
changing any of the like tweaking
characters at a team like runnin no I
mean that from what they've told me from
what I played it was very similar or it
was it it was the same thing from what
they've said they're even gonna you know
they're gonna be updating it
simultaneously on all platforms they
said they'd be open to cross play
between xbox one ps4 if that actually
happens but they they've said this a few
times they're not gonna do pc console
because i would just feel a little odd
back yeah they don't want the dreamcast
quake three things happen again right
where it'll go waiting for that one
publisher be like we do not want
cross-play between ps4 xbox okay what
publisher is not going to say that
that's what they want yeah it's good
yeah we want it's what i interjected
yeah so yeah
and so how does it I guess if it if it's
up it must felt it must have felt like
it was playing at a slightly different
pace right because I guess it's hard to
tell because a if you play with noobs
the first time around it's always going
to be a little bit slower as well were
you playing against Blizzard folk were
you playing with other journalists or
youtubers what what was it like it was
journalists and youtubers but they all
seem pretty experienced i was i consider
myself decent at shooters and overwatch
I've been playing a lot on PC and I was
you know like it was a challenge but it
was still it was it was like there were
fun matches for this kind of event I
think everybody there was pretty well
versed there weren't too many times I
really noticed major differences uh
there are certain times when the
constraints of the controller how many
buttons RR r I kind of felt a little
weird as opposed to the keyboard which
you can map really well merci
specifically you can switch from her
staff her healing damage buff staff to
her like automatic pistol yeah and on
the controller the default was to press
right on the d-pad so when you're in the
middle of a bite and then you want to
switch it you have to stop moving with
your left thumb or if like I started
bringing my right thumb over before I
remapped it just because I could keep
moving and not just get shot but you
know on the keyboard I just usually map
that to Q or something which is really
quick so i'll definitely there might be
some finagling am I want to do when I
map the buttons when the open beta
launches but I know it feels really good
it feels like you know they took their
time with it they've said they don't
want a favor one platform over the other
that's another publisher I always say
yeah but yeah like diablo 3 i think they
did a really good job of bringing it to
consoles it wasn't as fully fleshed out
as pc they don't have seasons but it
still felt good that's cool i'm yeah i
mean i guess this is probably one of the
first times are gonna try and do an
identical launch for both pc and
consoles for a visit anyway i guess the
other side of this you know how did it
look headed to play what was running in
60 frames a second to look sharp yet did
it i mean the art style sort of lends
itself to some sort of degree of
scalability kind of looks like right it
yeah it was 60 frames it looks I don't
notice any visual differences between
this and pc maybe because i don't think
the art style would really it doesn't
seem like an art style that you could
really jack up on pc for a noticeable
difference I'm sure side by side there's
probably like loads of you know lighting
and
you know what he's saying in bits and
bobs that are kind of not as not as
sharp as they will be on pc but you did
share didn't feel like it was
particularly like downgraded no it was
just a normal normal PlayStation 4 not
this 4.5 but uh what gets it out later
yeah but no it it looked it looked great
I don't have any complaints coming off
of a few hours with it I think pc might
be my preferred platform going forward
yeah although I'm sure I'll have a few
those friends that won't be playing on
PC like back home that I'd like to jump
on ps4 xbox one with and one of the
questions your Samba 15 saying may third
on consoles if you preorder a couple of
days if you don't yeah there's a couple
of different ways of selling this
actually at the moment is the the
origins edition and then there's like
special editions and whatnot as some of
the pre-order bonuses for different
character skins all that stuff I wonder
if that's actually if people are
interested in that at all the people who
haven't actually had a chance to play it
yet because why would you care about
skins if you hadn't actually in you know
pick to your favorite characters are and
last question on this did you feel find
yourself like favoring certain
characters over all the ones that you
wouldn't necessarily see yeah I feel
like Widowmaker I the bastion the Taurus
was the one that was Opie for a while
where it had the shield and I feel like
people have now gotten so good at
Widowmaker do you can just destroy
anyone he forgot a good sniper so I kind
of feel like they're gonna nerf er
anyway but did you feel like less people
were using characters like that sure
yeah I i played Hanzo for one match and
I noticed someone else playing
Widowmaker throughout the matches so
they seemed comfortable but it
definitely seems like Winston was one of
the ones I mercy that those are some of
the characters that I think just for the
purpose of the event I gravitated toward
because you know again I was used to
those like those Twitter your characters
I was used to on PC and there were some
that just felt more naturally suited to
the controller right um but I've been
playing shooters on controllers for like
a wild man yeah and you know like I
counter-strike and team fortress two
were the ones that i always think about
when I'm thinking about PC shooters and
wouldn't I ended up playing both those
on consoles later I got used to them
pretty fast so I'm expecting to adapt to
all the characters but there's
definitely somebody said about certain
characters working better on console
like Winston I think is one like a good
example just cuz he's some like male
a-leaping focus and then like you said
his his weapon pretty like gravitates
toward people yes sticks to them so i
knows that a little bit
yeah cool should be interesting to see
let Sarah May twenty-fourth worldwide
release and the good folks at blizzard
let us know if you're going to pick that
up yourself if you're going to pick it
up on xbox one or Playstation 4 or if
you're holding out for the pc version
let us know in the comments below Mike
you've played all the games Peter we're
not gonna talk to you at all for the
first 20 minutes of the show probably
I'm just window dressing how do you feel
about overwatch uh you know I'm
intrigued by it i usually don't get into
competitive shooters but i do like the
personality of the game and having
played a little bit of it at I thing was
PAX East last year I enjoyed it but
again I was going up against people who
were seemingly really good just probably
just being an event demo which kind of
curtailed my enjoyment a little bit so
you know we'll see like it'll depend if
if I'm up to snuff when I try to play
the game but I'm curious i definitely
want to give it a shot that'll be
interesting one because it's like was
like a month after gears of war if you
don't get in straight away that's some
sort of good at everything yeah like I
got all online shooter I got in a
titanfall right long after the fact and
I was able to adapt to that game pretty
well um but I don't know that's gonna be
the same case with overwatch because it
seemed to be far less forgiving than
something like titanfall I was playing
with Chris earlier today I love this I
like I really am enjoying over i'm quite
a lot like more than i've enjoyed an
online shooter in quite a while like I
feel like you know growing up playing
counter-strike and quake 3 and unreal
tournament all these games like I feel
kind of bored by most first-person
shooters yeah but there's something
about overwatch I think it's just a
strategic variability that happens kind
of like the first time I've a team
fortress and you're like oh yeah there's
like a weave couple of these ones
acceptance editor being whatever eight
characters i forgot i'm a tf2 maybe nine
and there's like this massive breath
things like 16 and I think you know
we're watching maybe even more actually
2120 was a yeah yeah it's really
interesting i bought up i'll be curious
to see what you think about dhoom 3
multiplayer cuz i brought and that was
really fun i definitely were called
something like quake three yeah i
actually need to play it up because i've
been super down on it since watching the
trailers like yeah it comes across maybe
it's just the marketing but it comes
across like they don't know why doom was
good i don't know how i feel about the
single player but a multiplayer was
definitely good and i went in there
Connor with like lukewarm anticipation
mmm I just kept getting back in line and
keep going it so yeah we'll see how that
pans out sweet looking forward to
you